one interesting aspect of your
relationship is you're in an open
relationship what's that like from a
game theoretic simulation perspective
what went into that calculation and like
how does that like how that started or
yeah how did that started sure um the
only relationships I've ever done has
been open relationships since I was like
in high school because I didn't really
understand like why wouldn't you be able
to like do other things but other people
but then just like have your main
partner basically so what what is an
open relationship generally speaking
that means you have one main partner not
a monogamous relationship like you're
somehow allowed like in different ways
um you can see other people's actually
sexually but like there is one main
okay or it doesn't have to be that for
some people but like I think it's
probably easier and we probably don't
really have time or the energy for like
more than like one person to like really
like what about like emotional
it's really complicated there's a lot of
complicated stuff going on under the
hood there yeah
um I think broadly speaking you've got
like polyamorous relationships and
you've got like open relationships where
polyamorous is like oh I've got like
three different girlfriends and we all
hang out or sometimes even live together
or three boyfriends whatever and then
you've got like open relationships which
is like oh you know like you can
basically hook up with other people and
then you've got like your main
relationship and that's it I think ours
is probably somewhere in the middle of
that um to where like we've got like
long-term friends some of them we hook
up with and that's kind of how we yeah
it's a delicate dance that uh explodes
every six months on itself if it does
explode you guys fight over it we fight
over some things yeah things happen yeah
I think it's mostly because a lot of
people can't handle it and they they
agree to something and then they realize
that they're way too cool and then they
get really obsessed and they think that
they can like get in there and then it
gets really dramatic have you figured it
out
I feel like we figure out things more
and more like when it comes to like
what's a good person for us to hang out
and what's not a good person for us to
hang out with or like I probably have
more opinions on like who he hangs out
with because he likes the [ __ ]
psychos yeah so you like this song you
like the not like The Crazy Ones like
the baby trap sort of women that's the
that's the ones and I don't understand
that because that affects me
that affects your game theoretically
yeah right uh you like to surround
yourself like in general you've talked
about with crazy people
I say crazy and I really shouldn't it's
a humorous way it's like yeah they're
very unstable very can be unstable but
people that are very unique like when I
meet this person that's like not boring
yeah not boring yeah and you said that
you're progressively becoming not boring
yourself no I think I'm pretty stable I
don't let them affect me much but so you
don't think they affect your Nah if I've
said that I've said a joke I think I've
like I've got my stuff like really well
figured out it's what allows me to
engage with people like this so easily
because I can engage I can make them
feel seen and heard and then if it gets
insane I can cut off and I can be chill
like very few things affect me in the
long term you guys experience jealousy
usually like whenever I feel like he's
not spending the like the amount of time
that I'm asking for and he spends it on
his video games or his stream or like he
sees someone else like more than he sees
me or something like that that would
like not be good because then it affects
like our relationship do you have a good
sense of like is it literally time or is
it the energy put into the it's probably
like if like if he's with me that like
the attention in the time like when he
hangs out with me and then there's also
probably at a time so if I feel like
something else is distracting too much
like it could be work or it could be a
friend or it could be anything like if I
feel like it starts to take away from
like me then I'm having an issue with it
I don't think he really cares much I
guess the only jealousy you experience
is probably when you feel like
um
like if I get upset about him seeing
someone too much and then I go see
someone more and then he's like why
can't I go see my friend more like as
much as you so like that's the sort of
like thing that we're trying to navigate
on I guess
I think we uh we we are like
diametrically opposed sometimes in terms
of how we view like engagement with
people or engagement with the world
sometimes so like on her end of the
spectrum like a perfect week for her
might be like being in a cabin
watching like fireflies at night going
hiking every morning going swimming at
the beach because it's like you're
taking in like the Grandeur of nature
you're like connected with yourself
you're like very at peace everything is
like chill and cool there's the wind the
feeling of nature everything that's like
her Peak living experience I like being
present yeah and like my Peak
experiences are like people trying to
destroy my life like the challenge of
like navigating a really complicated
discussion
um like you know several different
dramatic offense unfolding that my in my
career like these things are like very I
like the stress and the action and the
entertainment and everything's like very
cool for me so when we're together she
generally wants me to be like more chill
but if I don't feel like I'm being like
stimulated a lot then it's easy for like
my mind to wander somewhere else or yeah
that's kind of the issue yeah we have a
very different way of like engaging with
them so how can you find
happiness and Stillness I feel like if
you're just like aware of it and we're
trying our best like whenever we like
we're supposed to do this one thing so
let's say that we want to go to New York
and I'm like we should just like go out
and do this one specific thing we try to
find something that he enjoys doing like
um now that we're in Texas we can go
shooting or do something fun that he
enjoys then we can do it
um and then I think like
just like for me also to be aware
um that like when he spends a lot of
time on crazy people it's not because he
like loves them or wants to be with them
it's just because he likes being like
having having his life destroyed like
you said which I don't really do this is
a completely different thing so like for
me to like understand more like how he's
thinking because it's so different from
mine and for him to understand how I'm
thinking about things and like what I
prioritize in my life I think that's
like how we navigate but I think it's
good I think the differences can be good
like when we're finding a way yeah well
I think you're you're relatable
like I always tell people that like if
you're dating me for like more than a
few years like you get like a an award
like a war zone that you've survived
absolutely you're like a veteran you get
a medals and stuff and it's always like
I think there's probably been like six
different I don't think she says it
anymore but they're like six different
times in our relationship where she's
like is it always like this is this yeah
and like every next year it's the
beginning of about like you were lying
about that yeah you were not you were
like no it's just like right now I'm
having a huge argument online about
seeing the n-word in private and it's
just gonna be like this and I'm gonna be
streaming 24 hours a day and I'm like
we're like when are you gonna come to
bed it's been a week
I did playing League come into into this
uh I'm clean of League like six months
right now yeah what what do you uh hate
about legal aid I never humans
well speaking of which I my
participation in League involved on the
robot side good because
that's an improvement because uh uh both
with Starcraft 2 and and uh League of
Legends because open Ai and deepmind uh
both participate in creating bots and
those I was a professional soccer of two
players so I remember when the AI
started to play it's interesting the
types of restrictions that you'd have to
put on like a gaming robot to make it
like functional and not totally unfair
to the other side yeah to make a
human-like yeah was that interesting to
you to see AI be able to play those
video games I think in some ways people
think things are more complicated than
they actually are and I think video
games is one of those things where
really oh my God there's like a million
possibilities at every second and who
knows and it's like no there's like
three or four things going at any point
in time and I'm willing to bet that like
an AI could probably solve some of these
games like pretty easily
um especially if there are no
constraints on how they can learn yeah